uh who are some of these people that are
i just i i'm just trying not to violate
trust clearly it's a sip of milk yeah
yeah yeah maybe i'll just i'll plead the
i'll plead the milk
[Music]
well guys welcome to the ultimate sean
evans interview presented by dairy
farmers of america it is a cooperative
of over 11 000 dairy farmers dedicated
to putting more sustainably made dairy
on your tables and sean first and
foremost it's always good to see you and
i assume that you're excited because i'm
here but it's also a holiday that must
mean more to you than just about anybody
else it is world milk day today and june
is dairy month so how excited are you
for for a holiday that uh i'm sure means
more to you than me yeah you know i i
don't think it gets enough attention you
know what i mean like that can fly under
the radar for a lot of people but milk
it's been a such a safety net for me
over the years so it's about time that
we we give it the celebration that it
deserves i can't even put a number to
the amount of times i've seen you reach
for a glass of milk to help cut the heat
in the interviews that essentially get
very hot in a different regard but dairy
farmers of america is working to find
ways to keep the planet from getting too
hot like using solar energy and wind
turbines to cut emissions and so i
wanted to present to you these glasses
of milk to help cut some heat as well
if at any time in the interview the he's
already sipping but if at any time in
the interview the question gets maybe a
little too hot sure feel free to take a
sip to cool things down we inverted the
set you hot ones is normally on a very
dark set but we're brightening it up
today uh and i just wanted to say thanks
for having me here and i'm excited to
talk to you i'm excited too you know i
think we have a lot of chats offline you
know yeah but i don't think we've ever
sat down in any sort of like formal
setting like this so i'm excited
let's go back to the origin
crystal lake shawn evans
chicago's very own what was
full-headed hair
shawn evans like as a kid growing up
overall just a really
good experience good childhood good high
school experience and most of that the
constant through all that was just good
friends then the u of i is is the school
that you're obviously so very proud of
but then the story kind of
the story of your life could have gone a
bunch of different ways and i think for
a second you had an idea that it may go
a different way when i graduated uh
there was no immediate sort of tv job
there you know like there was no thing
that was like immediately there for me
after i graduated i went back to doing
architecture tours that i've done all
the way through college doing tours of
the chicago river and whatnot you told
me about this
so many years ago but that's something
that's always interesting to me
particularly because you still have it
down pat i'm not going to ask you to do
it now but i've seen you just do it on
command rewinding back to those days for
a second i imagine there were a bunch of
celebrities that took those tours some
of which eventually wound up on hot ones
that's true
i'll take a sip to that i haven't
thought about this until this second
i'll sit with you bro i'll sit with you
yeah you're right tyra banks didn't take
one of those tours i was going to say
but i wanted you to say it
now as long as we've been friends even
pre-hot ones i i never saw the food
connection i wonder if you maybe all
along had this vision of food or or
maybe it was working concessions at the
park district that kind of got you going
in the food realm
that was my first ever job
was uh working at the beach and selling
like popsicles to kids but no i think in
a lot of these things it was just um
like it comes when it comes to hot sauce
or whatever it was just all around the
show you know like i've always enjoyed
restaurants i've always enjoyed food
scenes when i travel or go somewhere i
like to you know figure out what is the
regional delicacy in that area and i
have to get my hands on one but it's not
like i was a hot sauce guy or like they
say in the key and peel episode like
found something i could do and built a
whole show around it it was just
something i had to build myself up to
and figure out and keep pace with even
before hot ones talk to me about the
beginning of the complex era you come
over from chicago just as a writer you
helped spawn what was complex news at
the time and it was three of you guys it
was you
jinx and emily three people that i
consider some of my best friends and
then here i came along as an intern at
the time yeah what do you remember about
the era of of complex news pre-hot ones
and maybe how that kind of helped
transition you to where we are today the
way that i got the job is in all-star
weekend 2014 we were supposed to do all
of these interviews right i didn't know
where they were gonna live or what was
gonna happen but it was right when
complex launched the youtube page and
the only person they had doing on camera
stuff was jinx and so
they were like hey these interviews that
we're you're doing can we just put them
on our youtube page like we just need to
populate this youtube page so i was like
sure like please do you know like i was
i was working as a copywriter at the
time and i was like if i can get a two
chainz interview on youtube that'll be
the best thing that's ever happened in
my entire pathetic life liked him enough
to offer me a job jack irwin uh back
then shout out to jack he called me
and uh took a little bit of convincing
but then yeah i ended up getting rid of
my apartment breaking my lease selling
all my stuff and i was in new york 30
days later you said that you needed some
convincing to take the job in fact if
i'm not mistaken you actually said no to
the job at first but then it wound up
circling back and and you were convinced
and you came and i'm glad that you did
so now hot ones is starting to come
around i remember the first time you
explained the show to me
uh i didn't quite get it like most
people yeah but the main thing that i
was confused about was to me
i remember vividly saying so they
finished all 10 wings but there's no
payoff and you were like well yeah
that's kind of the point like they go
through this super tumultuous thing
just to get like 15 seconds of plug time
yeah yeah and that's it that's the joke
how difficult at that time was it
explaining the show because on paper it
it just doesn't make sense yeah well i
thought it was like simple enough but i
don't think you know and if you look
early on there's not a lot of people
that really got it or like believed in
it and i think that honestly
we never could have built the thing that
we built if not for that i actually got
stuck in the studio
for the third ever episode of hot ones
which was machine gun kelly wow i was in
the room for that hot ones episode kind
of by chance but i was i was stuck in
there uh
and it quickly went from being stuck in
there to just being enamored by what was
happening and watching mgk just do laps
around the table and it was it was so
peculiar to me to watch this kind of
cerebral reaction to what was happening
so i remember going back to our desks at
the end of that day and i remember
turning to you and just being like bro i
think you got something here with your
show that was when i knew that we had
something to was that shoot when he was
just
cursing everybody out and doing laps
around the studio and like i was just
like this is so compelling in the room
that i know that it's going to translate
to the video even that much better and
i've never seen anything like this now
that the show's lasted long enough for
me to kind of be able to look back on
some things the things that i miss about
the old days are kind of just traveling
around going from hotel to hotel staying
up until four o'clock in the morning
like having the alarm go off at 6 30
getting all that stuff going to the
studio trying to execute a shoot and i
feel like i was so naive and delusional
we were really building something and i
was just bouncing around with chris all
the time now things are special to me
because they represent how far we've
come i remember back in those days like
when people came in they were sort of
like what am i doing here what is this
freak show that you guys have going on
here it was sort of half embarrassing to
do the show before and on top of that
your set doesn't help you out at all no
you got these black curtains and a table
and two chairs and like dominoes too
like we've popped this thing up in hotel
rooms before so it like looks even kind
of like sadder and weirder and crazier
or we like take the couch in bed and
like move them against the wall and just
pop up the set inside of a hotel room
and then have like
a super famous a-list movie star like
knock on the door and open it up but i
think that the magic of the show and
some of my
greatest memories and the testaments for
doing the show are when you come in with
that kind of a setup and the guest sits
down and you see on the second or third
wing their shoulders relax and then they
fall in they're hooked one of the first
true signs of success
uh
for me
was the co-sign from noriega yeah and
because obviously i'm from lefrak city
queens right and i remember you kind of
just showing me dms like yo bro look who
just dm me it'd be noriega you know so
who are
the dms now that get you excited that's
what i think is funny about hot ones is
that yeah you'll have like noriega in
the tent and then you'll also have like
bert kreischer in the tent stevo in the
tent like tom segura in the tent like
that's what i kind of like about it is
that it's this clubhouse this tree house
that's just
full of the biggest craziest
personalities and entertainment and then
yeah i do see that reflected back at me
a little bit i announced the bears draft
pick a couple weeks ago in vegas and i
walk to the green room and i see keegan
michael key first like huge episodes
that we ever had and when i see him he's
you know just immediately taken back to
that moment like
sean
people to this day
still
talk to me
about that interview you know like that
you know like doing all that so i feel
like once you leave the show you're just
like forever in the clubhouse because it
is that bizarre experience in this tent
you you didn't name any of these a-list
celebrities uh who are some of these
people i just i i'm just trying not to
violate trust that's a sip of milk yeah
yeah yeah maybe i'll just i'll plead the
i'll plead the milk what's had a steeper
decline
hot ones
recreation attempts
or your invites to media basketball runs
my invites to media basketball runs i
felt like i used to get those all the
time and i don't know what happened but
like
they stopped inviting me and it's kind
of like
i don't even understand it but you get
invited to that i do which is why i
brought it up though i remember the
recreation attempts being uh such an
integral and pivotal point in the
history of hot ones because i remember
how blatantly you would disrespect back
the people like i feel like the show is
too successful now for anyone to try to
recreate it does this still really
happen i have a totally different
relationship with it now than i did back
when i was wiling now
the show has gone on long enough you
know years hundreds of episodes i feel
like
most people who are gonna find it who
are or were gonna care about it have
already found it you know what i mean
can you give me the
mount rushmore of hot ones guests who
canceled
hold on
[Music]
i'll plead the milk on that because and
i'll tell you why
maybe they'll come back around because
that's happening this doesn't say that
they can't come around it it was just a
not now you know it's not a
never
sip up
when you watch back some of your
episodes of hot ones uh what is an
episode or what are some episodes that
you look at your performance and you're
like i hate the way i delivered that
question or i wish i would have
sequenced this better so early on i
don't think we took the interview as
seriously certainly not as seriously as
we do now so there's uh an interview
with like anthony rizzo in season one
that i cannot watch because i just
cringe at myself so hard there's only
been
one time
that i can think of that i've felt
really let down by you disappear okay
just go ahead and grab the milk you
really let me down one time in my life
as a friend especially as someone who
played the pitching mini game of mvp
baseball 2005 as much as you did yeah
yeah to watch you get on the mount
and [ __ ]
sail this pitch yeah 30 feet to the
right of well it was it was just it was
just high it was just high
what happened dog i will say that this
last summer i did one for the white sox
and it was just a perfect strike perfect
strike but here's what happened in my
defense and there is no defense but
here's what happened in my defense it
was like a hundred degrees it was like
the hottest day but they needed me in
the murakami jacket so i had that
jacket on they have like 50 people
behind home plate so you run out there
to the mound and you're so excited and
then you look over and trying to find
the catchers like trying to find waldo
you know there's like a billion people
that are right there i remember the
coach at the time madden for the cubs he
was like just don't bounce it so all of
those things were in my head i grip it
brand new baseball it's very slippery
very smooth very polished surface so i
let it rip and then it just
stayed high and probably like slammed
off that like brick backstop like it was
bad
what an excuse that was it was so
illustrious but i'm not buying anything
i thought about it a lot
throwing out the first pitch cardboard
cutout at the super bowl yeah being on
the celeb cam on the jumbotron at a
hockey game yeah announcing an nfl pick
i saw you with benny the bull yup tops
baseball card yeah madden commercial
yeah super bowl 52 pregame show
are you like jackie moon like what
well i think the only reason i do
anything that i do is just to infiltrate
the teams that i grew up watching so
yeah i feel like i caught them all at
this point outside of actual
accomplishments in the show and whatnot
those are my favorite things that i've
done but i can't express how many times
i've heard you tell people that your
goal in life was to be a game show host
and you've done it any tangible goal
that i've heard you say out of your
mouth has been accomplished and so i'm
wondering have you started to think
about the intangible goals i'm not
really a goal person
because i've already kind of done
five or ten laps around any expectation
i ever had for myself so it's all house
money now
so yeah i don't know my only goal is to
make the next episode that we have worth
watching for people and then the one
after that worth watching for people
what percent of the success of the show
do you think is you
what percent of the show do you think is
the spice
what percent do you think is like just
the current state of media and maybe the
decline of what once was those things
all have kind of an equal
share you know i think that
hook is unique
it has a quality about it where
celebrity is this lifestyle that by
definition is unobtainable but here on
this show
you get to see some of the most famous
people on the planet eating
a wing coated into bomb beyond insanity
going bright red and tearing from the
eyes you know you never see that
especially with images that are are so
carefully protected at all times i will
be as bold enough to say is that i do
think it is an excellent interview show
in the state of interview shows like i
really i really do believe that i
believe that it's more than anyone
should ever expect from a chickenwing
talk show on youtube how much of the
continuation of this show do you think
is you just chasing the dragon i think
of hot ones as catching lightning in a
bottle you know i really do and i don't
take any of that for granted now that i
work around people that i love
now that the show is in a place that is
just humming there's nothing else i'd
rather do there's nobody in
entertainment that i'd switch places
with like i really love what i do and it
feels a very comfortable place for me
and it feels like there's plenty more
runway how much longer you think it
lasts as long as i can do it as long as
people will have me i think i'm gonna do
it all right well shout out to dairy
farmers of america for making this
happen
sean let's let's toast real quick with
milk
i can't think of another time in my
whole life that i've
toasted with milk but
being that it does all that it does it
helps you cut the heat on hot ones and
you know dairy farmers of america are
also helping cut emissions
in our world i'm down to cheers with
milk for that so salute to dairy farmers
of america for helping us do this
interview and thank you for being a good
friend thank you speedy right back at
you doc
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for doing this bro
give me some love man i'll be doggie
[Music]
you